with the new Doctor Who Commander set
comes a brand new win condition card and
a new rule that you need to know if
you're going to be playing the doctors
and their companions in Commander let's
quickly take a look at the new card Gala
FR stands a six Min aorus legendary
enchantment that says when galfrey
stands enters the battlefield return all
doctor cards from your graveyard to your
hand at the beginning of your upkeep you
may put a doctor creature card from your
hand onto the battlefield then if you
control 13 or more doctors you win the
game so as depicted in this card the
most obvious way to win the game is
simply by playing all 13 doctors and The
Fugitive doctor and the War Doctor and
getting them onto the battlefield but
now thanks to the addition of these
cards and their creature type doctor
there are actually 47 other doctors you
can play too I'm of course talking about
the changelings changeling is a mechanic
that was first featured back in lawin in
2007 a card with this keyword is every
creature type no matter where it is not
only does this keyword appear on
creatures it also appears on a few
instance too you can also utilize cards
like marwood Nexus Arcane adaptation
conspiracy and strangely enough ruk
carum biologist just in case you wanted
to give all your slivers PhD
this also means if you wanted to run a
five color Doctor Who deck you can play
the boundless as the
commander the next question that usually
comes up is well if is every
creature type does that mean that they
can have a companion seeing as they are
a doctor doctor's companion is a new
keyword that features on a bunch of
different companion cards and there is a
companion for every color doctor's
companion is a variation on the partner
a keyword that featured back in
Commander
2016 doctor's companion says you can
have two commanders if the other is the
doctor Gavin Verge principal magic
designer at Wizards of the Coast has
just confirmed that creatures with
doctor's companion can partner only with
exactly a Time Lord doctor so because
is every creature type they cannot
have a companion sorry bud you're on
your own it's also worth pointing out
that the doctor's companion reminder
text does say you can have two
commanders if the other is the doctor so
they won't partner with any old doctor
they specifically need the
doctor now don't forget to like this
video If you learned something and if
you want to see my personal rankings for
all 15 doctors be sure to check out this
video here thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you in the next
next
one